I've never I'm growing up in a
neighborhood in old neighborhood you
know I grew up on a block where we all
hung together and we all stuck together
and we did everything together we spent
the night at each other houses we we ate
at each other houses we you know we we
played football in the streets to tag
and we were a close-knit group there was
like eight of us eight boys my age back
then growing up and you know we were
like two peas in a pod and what happened
was I started you know what I said I
would try everything once at least one
time and it started with the beer and
marijuana I think I started drinking at
11 about the same time started
experimenting with marijuana tried PCP
once heroin and all that kind of stuff
crack came a lot later and you know
growing up single parent scared to death
of being in a ghetto you know that's
like I said right when I turned 14 or 15
that's when the game epidemic is just
out of nowhere just came down and
there's like man you know they were
using these words and you know you can't
say this word you can't say that word
I'm like what cuz I see use this word
called blood something it was it was it
was a term of it was it was like arm
saying brother man but it had blood in
it and I remember my cousin telling me
say hey Eric hey man you can't use that
word man you can't use that you know you
have to use this
and said it I'm like what that's it okay
okay okay yeah I can do that but it feel
funny you know it's just out the blue
and shortly after that he came to crack
cocaine but leading up to the crack man
I was I was man I was a beer connoisseur
you know and I love the best money can
buy and when he came to marijuana you
know I remember on being busted to the
valley from junior from elementary
junior high in high school dropped out
in the tenth grade but um I used to go
out there to the valley and Wilton heals
when I was at Taft and come back with
the tie bug and it was that we that was
tied to a stick by us a bean stream
man I should come home with the tie but
the indica the purple hair and it was
real sticking it it smells so strong the
fellas in the neighborhood used to go
like wow we needs to give me their money
I mean to take the school to the next
day the purchase some for everybody so
we all put our little money together and
I take it man I'm going to school and I
cop and I bring it back to the
neighborhood man and I'll reporting like
there was no tomorrow
so I'd smoke drink beer with the Bandit
man from 11:00 to like 20 23 24 and
that's when the crack at the scene and
as she got a hold of me so fast I didn't
know what hit me all I remember is taken
one hit and never feeling the same it
took me somewhere that I that the
marijuana and alcohol just couldn't it
was like I had an out-of-body experience
but to keep it 100 with you will not
take that hit I feel like coming on
myself felt like I've done it and that's
what I like the body
I feel that you know man [ __ ] you know I
consider myself a freak back in the day
is as a youngster you know I was taking
down a [ __ ] all women young old I didn't
give a damn about the color none of that
stuff
I was always just trying to trying to
hit everything that I could you know cuz
that's what I was taught
that's where I was raised you know the
more women you have the more success you
are as a man you know it's like carbon
stripes when you're going to build buck
over something like that you know and I
had about three four women from 14 to my
20s you know about three four women at
one time you know in different areas
have one in the valley toward the
neighborhood three one cross town and um
I was juggling but you know and it was
hard work man it wasn't easy so I
developed the art of manipulation lying
cheating of course cheating stealing you
know they had to provide for these women
so this one wanted this that I'd go to
the store steal this for her you know
and this was for this one and all that
because I couldn't afford it but I'm
gonna once the crack cleaning man and
took me why never thought I'll go man
and the first hit minute took ahold of
me and wouldn't let go you know I
remember I remember blowing out to smoke
and
all my all my all my problems went away
I wasn't poor no more
I wasn't in a ghetto no more I was a
worthless you know I was somebody you
know I was somebody from another planet
because I damn sure I'm gonna be on
earth you know I really didn't man on
the inside
so from that first hit I fell in love
and it was a love-hate relationship
minutes tick me many places many dark
places and left some scores that if ever
be would mean but you can't see them
because they're gonna sell you I
remember Dillon inside inside the family
see inside the family it's a whole
nother story inside the household more
so than being on the streets in in in in
dealing with the fellas I love being on
the streets I love doing everything the
kids did and all that kind of stuff but
the real reason why I drunk and smoked
marijuana because me and my brother we
never got along we never saw the odd it
was always something going on with me
and my brother I remember my mom working
and she will leave us home you know I
come home from school he be there and um
I remember one time I was in the living
room listen to my radio and he said hey
turned it down and planted - well I
turned it down let me show you how low I
had it I'm laying on the floor in a
living room what my head pressed up and
gets the radio listening to it he came
off the bed boom snatched my radio well
put it on the ground and stomped on it
I'm like you got to be kidding me
and I never you know I must say that's
an unbelieving alone when it comes to
him I remember one time I don't know
what I did he chased me out the house
once in my underwear my fruit of the
looms in broad daylight I don't have no
shirt no shoes no socks no pants just my
underwear barefooted like 3:30 4 o'clock
in afternoon I hit them stairs hit the
porch hit the middle of the street and
take off like the world runner and he's
chasing me can't catch me who too fast
and I never forget all the neighbors
were all so young and old and it would
just watch me
it's like I was running a slow motion
looking past all these houses as I'm
running and seeing all these people just
looking you know like and I'm running
for my dear life I'd never forget that
so I use marijuana and I use beer to
gain that confidence so I could stand up
and in beats up and beat that man you
know because I like I set up and then up
growing up I was a mama's boy always was
always will be and it gave me the
courage you know just to stand up and
talk bad you know I didn't I didn't know
I didn't break your stuff and and do all
that kind of stuff as far as retaliation
but you know I start speaking up you
know a story standing up for myself and
um that's what it gave me it gave me
that that false courage but it was
enough because that's I needed I needed
something you know to deal with that
day-to-day thing but you know just the
city sibling rivalry man I don't know
what it was with me and my older brother
man
I think his thing was he wanted to he
wanted he was the big brother but he
want to play the father the father role
in a family you know it was my sister
Tracy Todd and me now Tracy's our oldest
ties the middle nan the baby so he feel
like he was obligated to be that father
figure also slow
that's a big brother but the father
figure didn't work you know it just
didn't work you know because he was
crossing crossing boundaries man you
know and um over and over again across
from those boundaries and I remember
running away and standing gone to my mom
come home from work as soon as my mom
get home I'll let let in on her ass
curse her the [ __ ] out
why would you dare to protect me why
would you do that you know what the [ __ ]
man some [ __ ] crazy mad man got
me up in here with this mother and I'm a
kid man and when she come home from work
I let in on her call it a be worth all
that stuff hurting so [ __ ] bad
because she couldn't help me I thought
it was sucked out I said man you know it
was her job that's that's well that's
well thought back then that's how I feel
you know she let me down you let me down
you know every time I tell you with some
encounter some she thought it was she
thought it was just like we just you
know we just you know just like kids
stuff but you know my thing is it ain't
nothing kid about anytime we get into or
anything in the immediate area he'll
grab it and it come at me with it
shoes baseball bat telescope that the
four problems that you put it on wrap
that up it came at me once pleats
anything books anything in arms you know
arms reach and here I go again I'm
taking off roadrunner and it over and
over again I'm a nice I used to stay out
all night just to keep them going home
so I had to escape
my reality because um I didn't know what
else to do
you know when people didn't people
didn't see it like I saw it but it was
always something going on it was always
something you know
let me change something oh we were so
ice my brother he was a sharp dresser so
he would wear his clothes he would go to
school with his clothes on come back the
next day but he still sleep I would grab
his shirt and pee insulted the dirty
clothes hamper put them on and go to
school because I like the way he dressed
and I want to be like him now mind you
if I come home from school and he's home
and he's seen me in his clothes he's
tearing my ass up like man what you
doing with my clothes on man I mean I
just you know and here we go again you
know and um he'll lose it but um I try
to I try you know I love my brother I do
we never got along but that only that'll
take away that I love them you know but
I I just wanted to uh I want to be like
them in in in in ways where we just
didn't we never talked at home we never
we never had that bomb we didn't do the
baseball thing together we didn't do the
football together we didn't do the
movies together we didn't do anything
together you know I remember him playing
football and as part did you say hey hey
I'll let your little brother come along
nah nah you know and it's used to kill
me I didn't let him want but that's to
say hey hey you know it's the
championship game them the four top
teams in Los Angeles is playing at the
Sports Arena
you know and back in the days I remember
it was Corson Danny Danny is in every
one one year LA hi my brother's a friend
made it
Los Angeles you know Helen University
but I always remember course in abandon
and then one year my cousin Thomas he
made it they made it to the championship
game at the Sports Arena in Jefferson
you know Jefferson High School man
enough it was even like me and I thought
that was like that was like going to the
Super Bowl you know for me being a kid
and getting ready going to high school
you know just having that dream of
playing at the Sports Arena in a
championship being the top four teams in
the California you know playing for at
all and that's that that was the only
thing that my mind that was driving me
back then I was driving me you know but
I happen hands full but that was the
only thing that really kept me kind of
like thinking over here there's a way
y'all and I'm gonna get my ass up out of
here you know and I thought it'd be to
football you know it was fast that
practice at that at an early age you
know had all the moves and all that you
know cuz shake you do the dance - no
laughs and I learned that the hard way
but nonetheless you know it served to
help me later but anywho one day woke up
and there was somebody hey check this
out man
yeah we gonna try this
oh this okay I'm like wow yeah man said
we call it rock I'm like what is it I
said well what we do is what they do is
the rich folk ether basin but we from
the ghetto we're gonna crush it up we're
gonna sprinkle it over some marijuana or
cigarettes and we're gonna call this the
Primo I said okay rolled it up and we
all I said deal okay I like that you
know and we used to break up there was a
diverse old you know everybody had their
own hustle
you know me me and and my crew
we you know we was we were the arm you
know we were we were notorious you know
for you know for hustling in a parking
lot you know we was notorious for you
know we was just we
good you know we master the art of that
everybody had their own little specialty
that they did so we would all meet on
the corner and two would go off here
drive away two will go this way and we
will go towards us see you know and had
a football and all that stuff and dog we
get our hustle on come back we all meet
back up we go get us the rock make sure
we had marijuana okay we got $25 cool
get the $20 rock get the nickel bag of
weed we're gonna roll to big to big
monster joints my bad promoters
cool so that's what we did and lo and
behold it became it just became a daily
and a daily thing soon as I get off from
school let's go you know we're gone I
couldn't wait to do that pre mop be in
school man what I wouldn't be in school
I'd be playing centipede outside of
school thinking about that can't wait to
get home put my hustle hand down get
that primo and everyday coming home from
school man if I didn't see nobody run up
go by my damn self and go get it and
with that came trouble because I became
a more reckless it had it became it had
more control over me in a short period
of time and before you know it I was
homeless by 18 three years of messing
around dippin and dappin
I was I was on the streets everybody
like oh hell no this boy's got bad it's
too bad man he said he's a wild man I'm
running around you know and I might be
missing in action three four days to
three weeks and all that kind of stuff
and I remember my mom taking me to
church for a time and so she to go to
the altar if you have trouble no let's
all go to the front and I'm standing up
and and the pastor you
hit like now everybody mind you
everybody before me I'm in line some
watches every time she says somebody
don't hit they fall out get to me you
know push them back a little bit I don't
fall because I don't feel like it
so she do it again okay I'll go here
fallout have somebody kissing and I'm
shaking and cavorting and slobbering at
the mouth and all that stuff after I get
up we get back home I say mom I'm get
ready go to the store right check it out
I have five dollars I was supposed to
put in the plate hell no I'm keeping at
five dollars let's say we get back to
the house and said hey mom I'm bored
down the street to get a pack of
cigarettes I'll be right back
and was gone for three weeks because it
killed me that I had to I didn't feel
like falling and I didn't feel nothing
but I had to go through that pony that
that show until you know and it just
crushed me on the inside
something like minutes shitty real with
the I was gone for three weeks last time
I went to church they didn't take me to
church remarked to that because they
know what it would affected me I don't
want to I didn't want to fall I didn't
feel like falling everybody else did but
I didn't feel like passing out and all
that [ __ ] but I did it and after I
was going for in three weeks
that was it they didn't invite me to
church no more because they knew now he
got to see his own way up out of this
one and so what happened was everybody
said my saving grace was Jail anyway I
did a nickel and dime stuff breaking
into cars stealing hubcaps battery stuff
like that getting the things up the
license plates the the years the little
stinks with the razor blade and all that
kind of stuff so that's what I was doing
man still my bicycles lawn mower some
people's you know whatever man whatever
was around you know [ __ ] you know if I
can get it it was it was it was a done
deal you know my special kid was stores
you know call these stories you know
surfs pants and verse that whatever and
everybody thought this my saving grace
was Jail so I'll be gone first time they
like ate much County then I caught a
strong-arm robbery because I demanded
some money from a guy and he didn't want
to give it up so I'm talking for it and
I lost but they gave me a stronger armed
robbery and I did 16 months in prison
went to fire camp they had weights back
then so you know working old numbers
fire camp I fight these fires and all
the kind of stuff so I come home and I'm
just like this new creation now my jaw
got 16 months I've been gone 10 months
so I come back to the old neighborhood
and I said within two days I'm back
right where I left off picked up right
where I left off and I'm at hon [ __ ] did
I get here
how'd I get this big how did I get in
this bad of shape this soon because I
didn't know that emotionally mentally I
was I was the same old scare kid same
old one scared of his own shadow had all
this different stuff going on the side
of me even away from home that's it was
driving me I couldn't sleep at night I
was having nightmares and dreams in this
Anette about what awaited me and not
dreaded it if I could have went anywhere
else but my old neighborhood when they
released me for prison I would've but I
couldn't admit that to nobody because I
know what was waiting on me I know what
was waiting and it only got worse before
it got better it got more dangerous
being on the streets you know the
children's was more rampant the police
was around more did crack them took over
the whole neighborhood everybody was on
it
[ __ ] they had a crack house every other
house seemed like in my neighborhood not
only every corner but every other house
somebody smoking somebody selling it
[ __ ] I couldn't escape that if I wanted
to everyone
turn oh yeah they got over here yeah
they got the good stuff over here oh I'm
gonna check this out how long you been
gone oh yeah you're gonna love this one
man and they got the new Memphis of when
you when you smoking now they man hold
your neck and all that kind of stuff you
take a hit hold it and grab you on the
side of your neck and all that [ __ ]
okay soon you blow it off you pass out
and hit your head and all that I mean I
went through all of that you know in the
name of PIP net effect you know getting
that booty all that good one you know
one dumb and it be coming in the
beginning it was fun man it was
something different you know it took me
away he gave me everything it did suck
for me man i worse can't describe what
it did but it did something until this
day I can't describe it in words but
whatever was it was it was enough to
hold me it keep me in his grips almost
30 years so I had this love-hate
relationship or crack cocaine it was my
best friend then it became over cinema
and I've been going to prison man and
I'm I'm going to prison and okay so I
think second time working out still
working out so I'll come home but like
um though the rock and I remember I
think that the mouth six seven days trip
of going and coming back on [ __ ]
swole I said oh man you you look like a
superhero man you just got the [ __ ]
perfect body like god damn I said oh
yeah I know where to go now you're on me
when it gets too hard on the streets
where I just can't take it I know where
to go where I can rest take two just
take a chill get away from the [ __ ]
man with the family thing the game thing
in the crack thing I know what is escape
I know where to go get away from all
this [ __ ] and that's what I did when
it's time for me to check out your
showing after that yes I did man
I'll do something to get in trouble cuz
I just got tired of dealing with the
[ __ ] on his Therese man I needed Calgon
take me away and here to come and in it
in in in form of a black and white
police court man I can't man will kick
you my [ __ ] so long hurry up man
I can't take no more this over here
driving me crazy you know so even though
it feels like problems everything was
compounding and pecking upon me you know
but I did what I did best and that was
run escape I know how to escape if it
wasn't do drugs and alcohol it was to
leave on the streets going to that other
place my home away from home which I
spent more time in prison over the years
than I did on the streets and that's
reality before was all said and done so
being out here was my home away from
home that was my real home almost 30
years because I were bathroom of it I
remember coming home staying home for
two days and went right back that's two
days two days my momma said oh man I
can't believe it I can't believe you
stayed on you own you're here for two
days
why my step three years would have 21
months Oh daddy nothing mama that's what
I'm that's what I see it you know muster
up this foster over that ain't nothing I
could do that on my head remember today
I'm it was something because instead of
bonding and building a healthy loving
relationship on my blood my siblings
every time I disappeared my time away
from home got longer and longer she went
through 16 months four years three years
then all the violations in between so
instead of building relationships with
my sister my brother things just got
worse every time I came home it's the
same [ __ ] going on but just turned up
not you too so it was more intense
meeting him it was more intense on my
smoking on my husband you know you just
turn that [ __ ] up up to a whole nother
level and man I was always trying to
play catch up always playing catch
always trying to play catch up love I'm
always behind I always trying to find my
way never get to some [ __ ] what's going
on man it changed over here going to
change over there and so on so I ain't
here no more
or this three in here no more I just
changed I'm like what I'm like man felt
like I was in the Stone Age every time
I'll leave and come back home I was get
that further further further behind I
didn't have no relationship a real
relationship with my mom my sister my
brother my nephews come along I
have no relationship with him I'm an
uncle I love him but I'm gon do both of
my nephew's childhood you know and my
sister was the single parent and and I
was taking man to be an uncle they have
opportunity to deal with my nephews you
know it was a dream come true when she
first had to go out Chris excuse me my
nephew can we shut the other one it's
like wow I wasn't tipping him but I
would be be there for this one that's a
damn lie because I wasn't I didn't I
wasn't I wasn't able to be there like I
wanted to like I needed to you know and
they have this old saying um you know
the father in the footsteps of the dead
you know and he was absolute E and even
though I didn't have any kids on my own
I was an absentee uncle and I thought it
a it'll be a deterrent for me wanting to
mess up but after about my fourth trip
to prison I'm like man this [ __ ] ain't
nothin it wasn't no deterrent oh man if
you do this you're gonna go to prick man
I don't give a [ __ ] I don't care
Prison don't scare me smoke all the
crack in California you got all the
drink smoke all the weed Rob still do
what I do because it wasn't no deterrent
it wasn't it wasn't a factor and in in
me wanting to change it and and try
something different because by then
meant I was in too deep and I was lost
in the sauce man so even though now in
retrospect man I was just I mean I just
went to that plantation bro I went to
the plantation yes sir and I had to do a
[ __ ] bidding yes sir for a
little bit of nothing and I bet it did
up and if I didn't do whatever some
consequences you know all that kind of
stuff anywho man so I'm back and forth
you know I'm working in the kitchen
working for three cents
five six seven cents an hour you know at
the end of the month I get
$14 you don't think I'm balling Wow it's
time to go to the canteen for this fill
out your canteen slip man kitchen
workers go early we go first
you know because you guys you know
service simply service up in here you
serve the people all that kind of stuff
timorous ok that's cool that's cool you
know and get my little soups and my
little bag of chips and my honey buzzing
and I'm like wow you know I'm good you
know but I uh I had a place where I can
go where I feel safe but afterward I had
to worry about stuff but not to the
degree I was on the streets I didn't
have the crack around me you messing
with me and driving me crazy because I
just had to had a shift and I couldn't
live without it I couldn't live with it
or without it I didn't have a
relationship or nobody in my immediate
family so when I'm going to prison I
just read we work out and worked in the
kitchen you know and out of all those
trips to prison man I learned that there
were some things that I that I had to
address when I was there man and the
biggest one for me was a cell Patriot I
wouldn't admit it but I hated men I
hated me I hated being black because of
the circumstances man that I was brought
up in year you took me home don't know
I'm good man I'm fine yeah everything's
ok so brother piecing all that [ __ ]
she'll be told I couldn't stand being
black pork and in real trouble you know
and I just saw the writing on the wall
man I'm like oh man I see what I'm
destined for by the way things are
lining up and I saw that [ __ ] early on
in the game sod it wasn't nothing that
could stop me from going that row and
have enough role models didn't have
enough people I really care about the
next man we was all in the same boat
everybody was poor distraught impressed
and all that [ __ ]
nobody would we wouldn't talk about it
as kids you know running around with
holy shoes and all that [ __ ]
hand-me-down clothes and all that
I've been memorized to walk to school
walking to school
slide my foot because both of my shoes
that had big-ass holes at the bottom of
them as to put newspaper in court board
so I'm walking to school one
other one suing somebody soon as I've
left my foot up somebody's see me
talking get them talking then they get
the laugh and the clowning and all that
kind of stuff man I said I hate that
[ __ ] man
and having pants that were too small so
I have to wear them way down here and
they call sag in the day but I was doing
that [ __ ] way back in the days because
the pants were hand-me-down they were
given to me you know so have another
kids and look at me a certain kind of
way when I'm in school because I was
busted out to the Valley Schools so
decent will give me that look and I know
what that look man you know I feel sorry
for this do you see had those little
lunch things those up for free food you
know for the lunches and breakfasts and
stuff and people used to get on the
other side with their little change in
dollars and that's to get over here with
the meal tickets man and what's it no
shame in a game with nothing you know
cuz I've I interpret you know [ __ ] for
repaying full don't matter you know if a
some changed me I'd rather use a ticket
because I can keep the little dollar in
the quarter whatever it was you know
that out a safe from not mind it so that
really didn't bother me but just the
looks that I got knowing that it wasn't
so much as how they saw me or what they
said or what they thought but more so
what I thought the filter bought me and
that's when the self hatred came in had
cuz it was in the gut there wasn't a
damn thing I can do about it you know
and the only thing got to do was wrong
took my children wrong and I just added
to it I couldn't stand up for myself I
couldn't I couldn't I couldn't fight for
me and nothing unless I have the
marijuana to alcohol you know and
whatever they wouldn't induce with the
trick that just amplified all the other
stuff that I was old man you know
so when that [ __ ] I'll just almost drove
me crazy you know because um I just
couldn't you know I smoked so much man
it is so much man but if it wasn't for
prison I were to being be it or would
have been indeed and that's the God's
honest truth
prison safe model life and then and then
in another in another sense you know I
felt myself in there I found me you know
because I ran there thinking I was
hiding and escaping my my reality but um
that's why I found solace man that's
where I had time to really do some
soul-searching I remember one year I
went to prison think it was forgotten
anyway I've read all black history books
before the mayflower the Middle Passage
and all that stuff I said wow man great
contribution justice I said Wow and that
kind of changed my mind's my mind about
me because I'm just in school being
being bused to the valley on all the
white folks we read this is junior
elementary junior high history books the
first two pages of every book was on
slavery the first two pages slavery so
I'm two three black kids up in here man
and we knew we read about this [ __ ] and
I'm if I can turn red I were to turn red
but I think I must have turned purple
every time the history class we read
about the slavery man that was the
beginning of every history book man
that's what started with and my god
I see can't they put this in the middle
towards the end because this is that
this is a story in all place man that
all eyes on me I'm like Oh duh and I
hated that I hated it man I hated being
in that predicament man I being wanted a
few token black years man at this white
school man in history class
speaking on slit that it just dear some
to me man and even to this day it
bothers me but not as much as it did
back then I had nobody to talk to you
back then you know I didn't mess with
nobody in elementary junior high I was
alone dat into I stay to myself they're
my own thing talk to a few people but
pretty much didn't build my
relationships and not like that didn't
have enough friends back then but um
yeah man it was just a prison I read all
those books start to see things
differently and then I guess when as
soon is ready the teacher beer so I
think after like 19 trips to prison my
saving grace thank you I just see I
didn't sit back then but now I do
I was I was really ready for that change
from from the inside out I knew
something had to be different because I
have been going so many times I knew if
something didn't happen this last time
that it was just gonna be just I'm just
gonna that's it it's a wrap
you know and then what happened was the
last time you know I went to the same
prison three times in a row one
back-to-back-to-back-to-back same one
three it's back back back the same one
so all three times they they see me come
to go see me come like damn you back
again yeah the third time I did the same
thing I did the other two times I did
the self-help classes I did Islamic
services I did the church I did all that
stuff
I work don't like I did I've been doing
because it work for me it helped me [ __ ]
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna stop doing
with help me while I was in here I went
to the library I read all the books that
I could find
I loved autobiographies I got burnt out
on black history because it my whole
prison term I read none but there so I
was like I'm good I don't have to read
another page I don't have to hear about
another contribution that we made back
and I'm good you know I'm good I'm okay
with me now you know so the self-hatred
left me but I carried that a long time
and I should triple our talk even down
here when I see the young black man and
I see that look oh I know that look I
had the same look I had the same look
anger despair
I'm gonna test somebody's head off that
was me I know what it is because I went
through it
made it to the other side with a
blessing
what a blessing but chef realization is
the best one and only way you won't
learn that is by your own experience
because your own experiences can be your
best teacher I read many books in black
history but me living as a black man in
California in Los Angeles back in the
time of the gang is the crack and all
that [ __ ] epidemics you know man
that's the story myself you know that's
you said I survived a book on surviving
it's the streets of Los Angeles during
the 80s that was the worst time of my
life and it was out of us it was out of
my control you know and on so what
happened was man the last time something
had to happen and I did everything I did
the last time but he said when the
students are ready to teacher will
appear and lo and behold teachers I had
many teachers appear my last term and
they just fed me they just feet and we
did this stuff you know year at the year
at the year I'm building these
relationships with they're inside of
prison that I never got to do on the
streets you know I got the building's
relationship with his teachers I don't
half of my sister I got to develop these
relationships with these men that and
half of my brother never thought I'd get
it there never thought I get the healing
there never thought I'll be free there I
was set free from the bondage of the
[ __ ] and all that stuff that I was
going through I was set free in there I
was able took to sit down build a
relationship healthy loving relationship
without no strings attached phenomenal
material motors all the Bulls should I
been through him on the streets man
doing the crappy academic and all the
things I've done leading up to going to
prison I needed a break from all that
stuff especially when I was doing my
little thing in the entertainment field
I really needed a break from that ship
and I got it man
but it was building up it was building
up so once I look once I've said enough
enough is enough
it was already taking his toll on my
soul when I got back and store doing the
same thing but ever end up in prison it
last time I was ready man because I was
always away from her for so long by
working you know in the amateur dope of
audience kind of thing so that kept me
that kept me smoking you know kept my
kept me smoking man like I was a Pied
Piper kept money in my pocket and after
actually nobody for no no to cure myself
supply support him on one habit right on
you know and I was like the Pied Piper
you know I come home from from doing me
a scene you go back an old neighborhood
hey you come on come on let's go you
know I'm gonna me go take me some for
200 yeah come on y'all
hear hear you know we smoking with
impunity but the band I'm the
[ __ ] man until I get broke and
want some broke it's like okay so when I
was supposed to do another arm
hey I need some work man you got
anything set up for me Oh
two weeks from now damn you can do that
earlier than two weeks that kind of
thing
so since Snug could be set up where I
can get some more money to tide me over
that I had to resort back to the the
still me stuff like that you know them
stores and that's time the prison man
I'll build something that uh when he
came by I found peace
I found serenity I have peace money can
buy that and the soul is so valuable
I wouldn't trade it for nothing in the
world today yeah I hadn't missed I had a
missed steps I've had missed steps along
the way it's just I've been home [ __ ] I
wish I was perfect wish I could have
said I got through without without
stumbling you know I always tell myself
man I have two left feet so I have to be
extra careful when I walk cause I don't
have a right and a left so it's easier
it's more easier for me to
all trip before because I have to
something be mindful extra careful you
know and but we're certainly a port man
aside from everything goes man no matter
what goes on in mob rule today rain
shine good bad in between I'm okay man
because I'm okay with me you know I
don't mean I know my worth my time is
important I'm important I'm somebody and
I try to represent to the best of my
abilities man as I just just as as a I
know I'm not special I'm not unique but
what I put out there I just try to put
some up there just so you know when you
look you do to double take for whatever
reason it might be the most I don't know
what it is and really don't care but I
would want to be something good for for
me making a difference in some kind of
way not being about how I look or all
that kind of stuff
of what I would I contribute what I
bring you know to the to the day to the
real to my family to my friends and so
forth to someone you know wow I can kill
my parents on one hand and I met them in
prison and still have a relationship of
the day and it is a beautiful Manas I
never imagined that I would be okay with
me that I would be okay with all the
things I've been through him and all of
the things up I my family through all
the hurdle calls and all that kind of
stuff to my family unto myself man
because if somebody but it did me like I
did myself growing up I would it kill
the ass and been doing life there's
somebody wouldn't did me the way I did
me so now when I wake up in the morning
I look in the mirror I know this was
looking back I take notice who was
looking back and I said you know what
that person is dependent on me a person
needs me and I got to be there for that
person got to be there 100% I got to
bring my a-game because he's all like
God and I said we're rolling day I'm cut
fair exchange there's no robbery okay
thank you
you